nous sommes le 21 janvier 1871 les
prussiens arrive au nord de dijon 4000
hommes en trois colonnes qui suivent les
routes de langres troyes et paris
il faut à tout prix les arrêter les
repousser dès les premières heures du
jour des combats éclatent un peu partout
dans ce bois près de hauteville en fin
de matinée a lieu un affrontement des
plus sanglants qui se termine au corps à
corps
anne officiers garibaldiens le général
bosse à croquer et tués
il commande la première brigade de
l'armée des vosges pour eux c'est la
troisième bataille de la journée d'abord
dans le val suzon puis à darois aient
enfin ici ou là moitié d'entre eux sont
tués ou blessés le 21 janvier 1871 toute
la zone où nous nous trouvons ici même a
été véritablement un champ carnage
pourquoi parce que beaussac savait qu'il
ne serait pas renforcé pour une raison
excessivement simple c'est que les
unités garibaldienne qui couvrait la
route de paris à hauteur de plombières
avaient été débordées enfoncé dans la
journée que en ce qui concerne les
autres unités de garibaldi dans le
secteur de la route 10 sur tille à
messigny et vantoux elle avait été
également déborder enfoncé au pied de
l'église de messigny et vantoux re1
soldats en tenue régulière tourner son
visage à l'est
à l'origine ce devait être un
garibaldiens car ici ce sont eux qui
canarde les prussiens
ils ne sont pas assez nombreux demandent
du renfort 600 hommes qui arrivent
l'après midi on se bat jusqu'au soir
dans les rues on s'est battu on s'est
battus à la lisière du village
mais au coeur du village lui même je
vous confirme qu'il ya eu des combats et
on l'a ramassé des corps après
évidemment cette bataille beaucoup
repose au cimetière de messi ni les
prussiens eux ont quand même réussi à
avancer de 10 km
ils ont installé leur qg et leurs
blessés tout près d'hauteville ici dans
la ferme de changer garibaldi le sait il
ne faut pas que les prussiens prennent
la butte de fontaine c'est la porte
ouverte sur 10 jan le lendemain le 22
les prussiens attaque la butte de talent
dans les vignes les combats sont
meurtriers acharnée les troupes
garibaldienne contre attaque le champ de
bataille s'élargit contourne des et
garibaldi fini par s'emparer de
hauteville le 23 janvier les troupes
prussiennes se sont déplacés et
concentrent leurs attaques en passant
par la route de langres le château de
pouilly est pris pour cible et son
travail et si donc les garde-mobiles des
francs tireurs de différentes origines
étaient autour du château ont tenté de
résister ils n'ont pas su résister
puisqu'ils étaient en trop faible nombre
est très mal équipé
seuls neuf ont résisté à l'intérieur du
château les prussiens en mille feux au
château l'histoire retient qu'un franc
tireurs auraient été jetés vivants dans
le brasier dans la plaine entre le
château de pouilly et dijon brrr il n'y
a qu'un seul bâtiment lusine bargy les
français ils prennent position attendent
la proche des prussiens
c'est un carnage ou de la charmette un
monument au mort allemand perpétue le
souvenir des tués lors de cette bataille
lorsque la fusillade cesse les prussiens
bat en retraite
un jeune soldat victor kurt a saisi le
drapeau du 61e régiment poméranien c'est
l'une des rares victoires françaises en
1871 à dijon elle a donné son nom à
l'avenue du drapeau en mémoire de ces
combats un monument érigé en 1876 à
fontaine-lès-dijon est dédié aux gardes
mobiles de saône et loire
l'aviron de l'isère des alpes maritimes
et aux soldats de toutes les armes avec
cette supplique ne nous oubliez pas
[Musique]